In the following table,
is y a function of x?
In order for y to
be a function of x,
for any x that we input into
our little function box--
so let's say this is
y as a function of x.
It needs to spit out
only one value of y.
If it spit out
multiple values of y,
then it might be a
relationship, but it's not
going to be a function.
So this is a function.
This is a function.
If we had a situation where
if we input x into a box,
it could be multiple
possible y's,
then this is not a function.
So let's think about this
table right over here.
When x is equal to 1,
we get y is equal to 1.
But when x is equal to 1
again, all of a sudden,
y is equal to 2.
So here we have a
situation where we input 1
into our little
relationship box,
and when we input 1 into
our relationship box,
we could get a 1, or
we could get a 2 for y.
So this is definitely
not a function.
For any input into
a function, it
has to map to
exactly one output.
Here it's mapping
to two outputs.
So this is not a function.